[Music]
one of the best ways to keep your users
engaged on a native mobile app is to
send push notifications today I'm going
to show you how to set up firebase cloud
messaging with ionic to do just that
this video is going to be a lot of fun
because it ties together many of the
resources in the firebase platform
including firestore cloud functions
messaging and user aw by the end of this
video you'll have a flexible
notifications feature designed to work
on both iOS and Android if you're new
here make sure to LIKE and subscribe and
you can find all of the source code at
angular firebase comm and join the slack
team so we can chat about your questions
together the first thing I'll do is
generate a brand new ionic app I'm using
the tabs template but that part is
completely optional then I'm going to go
into the config dot XML file and make
sure that we have a custom widget ID
that we can use to register our project
with firebase we're targeting native
mobile apps on the App Store so what
we're going to do is register our app on
the firebase console for both iOS and
Android for both platforms the only
thing you have to do is enter your ID
and click through the steps you don't
need to download the SDK or anything
like that when you finish the process
you'll want to download your config file
for both platforms and save it in the
root of your ionic project for Android
it's the Google services JSON file and
for iOS it's the Google service -
info.plist file now that our app is
registered with firebase let's go ahead
and add our dependencies first we have
angularfire 2 which gives us access to
the firestore database then we have the
firebase cordova plugin for ionic which
is going to give us access to native
features for ios and android follow the
official install instructions for both
packages and then generate a custom
ionic provider called
FCM will use this provider to create a
tightly integrated cross-platform
notifications feature after following
these steps you should have an app
module that looks something like this
we're importing an angular fire as well
as firestorm then adding our firebase
credentials then we should also have the
firebase native plugin as well as our
custom FCM provider angular fire goes in
the import section and our firebase
plug-in goes down here in the providers
section before we write any more code I
want to show you exactly how this
feature works from the user perspective
here we have an iPhone and it's
prompting the user to allow permission
to send push notifications when the user
clicks allow it's going to give us a
token that will then be saved in the
firestore database on that document
we'll also save the user ID so we can
query all the users devices and send out
a notification to every single device
that that user has registered if the
user has their device open it's going to
bring up a toast notification on that
device when the device is open it's the
developer's responsibility to handle the
notification when the app is in the
background will actually send a push
notification through the native device
then I'll show you how to send push
notifications directly from the firebase
console and also programmatically via
cloud functions most of the magic is
going to happen in our FCM provider so
let's go ahead and start there first
we'll bring in the firebase plug-in as
well as platform and firestore then we
can inject these in the constructor from
there its first responsibility is to
retrieve the actual token from the user
which is just permission to send
notifications to this device we'll set
this up as an async function and then we
need to check for the platform that
we're actually retrieving this token
from when it's Android we just need to
call our native plugin get token and
that's going to resolve with the token
when it's iOS we have one additional
step and that is to request permission
from the user that's going to trigger
the iOS pop-up modal that I showed you
earlier then lastly we could check to
see if this is a web application and
send a notification that way as well for
right now I'm just going to leave this
as a to-do because I've already covered
it in episode 64 and also angularfire 2
is going to be releasing a cloud
messaging module in the near future so
you can count on another video when that
happens then the final thing we'll do in
this method is save that token to
firestore which is just a big long
string I'm going to extract this out
into a different method and if we don't
have a token we'll just return otherwise
we're going to make a reference to the
devices collection in fire store the
goal is to send a notification to every
device
that a user has registered so we also
want to save the user ID on this
document
I'm just hard coding a test user but in
real life you'd want to use the firebase
auth UID and the token is just a string
so we can actually use that as the
document ID and that's important because
it ensures that every device in
firestore has a unique ID lastly to
listen to notifications all we have to
do is call on notification open and that
returns an observable that we can use in
the front-end and I should point out
that specifically for native apps you'd
want to use a different method for web
apps now we need to run the get token
method in one of our components for now
I'm putting it in the home component but
you could also put it in the app
component or some other root level page
inside this component we'll want to
import our FCM provider as well as the
toast controller from ionic and the tap
operator from rxjs then we can inject
those in the constructor getting that
token from the user is just a matter of
calling this method and it's going to
handle everything else automatically on
their device once we have the token we
want to listen for incoming messages and
handle them accordingly
ionic makes this really easy because it
has a built-in toast notification
service so we can listen to our
notifications and then use that tap
operator to show a toast whenever a new
message comes through every message will
have a body and then we'll show it for
three seconds and then it will
automatically hide that's an observable
so the last thing we have to do is
subscribe to it let's go ahead and test
it out by sending a message directly
from the firebase console you'll need to
have an emulator running in this case I
have Android going then I'm going to
enter some message text and when the
apps open for the first time it should
generate a device token in firestore go
ahead and copy that token and then
return back to the notifications tab so
here you can send the notification to a
single device or to a topic or to a user
segment we'll get more into that when I
release my full I on it course but for
right now we'll just send it to a single
device click send and you should see it
pop up in the emulator cool so that's
really convenient but in most cases
we're going to send notifications
programmatically using cloud functions
that's what I'll show you next but first
I want to point out that if your build
i OS you also need to enable push
notifications in your project in Xcode
you also need an Apple Developer account
and things like that but that's beyond
the scope of this video what we want to
do next is build a cloud function that
will notify a user whenever they get a
new subscriber or follower or some other
important event happens on their account
so run firebase and net functions which
will create a functions directory in the
root of your project I'm using
typescript for my function so I'm going
to go into the functions directory to
the source index TS file then we need to
initialize the firebase admin SDK and
I'm exporting a function called new
subscriber notification this function is
going to run whenever we have a new
firestore document created in the
subscribers collection so you could
think of this in the same way that you
think of YouTube subscribers what we
want to do is notify the owner of that
channel whenever they get a new
subscriber we can make this an async
function to return a promise which is
required in cloud functions and then
we'll get the data from that document by
calling event data data each document
should have a user ID which is the owner
of the channel and a subscriber which is
the user who is subscribing to that
channel then we can use this information
to format the actual notification
content so we'll set a title of new
subscriber and then we'll say subscriber
name is following your content you can
also add an icon image as well the next
step is to find all the device tokens
that belong to a given user to do that
we make a reference to firestorm and
then we reference the device's
collection and filter it by that user ID
by saying where user ID equals this user
ID we can retrieve that data one time by
calling get on it and then we'll set up
an empty array for each of the tokens
that we want to send a message to then
devices is a snapshot query so we need
to call for each on it and then for each
token in that query we're going to put
it in our tokens array then the final
step is to just call admin messaging
send to device with that tokens array
and the corresponding payload now go
ahead and deploy your function and we
should be ready to put it to use in this
case I have my
function set up to trigger on the
subscribers collection so I'm creating a
new document in that collection and
making sure the user ID matches test
user which we set up in our ionic app
and sure enough after we create that
document we get the notification in the
device as expected in the next few days
I'm going to release a fully on a course
that will go into much greater detail on
firebase Cloud messaging and give you a
solid starter template for building your
own native mobile ionic apps if you're
an active pro member you'll be able to
enroll in that course for free thanks
for watching and I'll see you soon